you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens what's up everybody
welcome to e3 2016 here what did you
just say Miller funny that's calling
from kind of funny that is Chris waters
from gamespot com how are you great
happiness on your co-op see thanks for
coming on the stage this is a hot
collabo we did last year and this year
it's gonna be even hotter yeah taking
off more clothes no and also because
we're kicking off with this gentleman
Herman Holtz how are ya Herman of course
everybody from guerrilla games work out
a little thing called horizon zero dawn
it's right tiny this demo tiny little
ganna did you think about bringing
something impressive III bring this
thing or walking her nose awesome holy
crap was it awesome it was just a game
it's part of the game it was part of a
quest it's not even a demo I consider it
our game that's the craziest part about
it you were saying earlier there yeah
it's not you didn't make a vertical
slice you didn't make a demo you just
opened up the world and let people into
it exactly so last year we had that big
boss fight and we had a lawyer lead
heroine taking it on yeah and this year
we just wanted to concentrate on
everything that's part of its open world
seeing this over world it's got RPG
elements throw in some new new machines
a lot of new abilities for the player
character so we want to bring it all and
kind of show you the game is we're gonna
play it you can have some hands-on time
because we've got to do the show for
here when you're out of this fast yeah
and you minutes left so I Herman I mean
coming into III you know you one kind of
funnies game is show last time around
with horizon in your debut gratulations
coming into this one is that in your
mind you know you have to do something
bigger and better than last time uh not
so much scoring the yeah I want to win
the award
I think we you realize that when you
come out when you first announced that
everybody's going to love it because
it's great and there is such a thing
it's kind of the second the second album
you need to prove that it's actually a
game sure and that's why we just came
out simply with the game it's what you
saw the press conference here you watch
the sony press conference last night
yeah a little bit i caught it that's
just basically a capture 2 playthrough
of the game seven minutes word that
that's that's what it is now you know of
course Colin and I fans gorilla fans of
horizon Chris what did you think that
what you saw of horizon yeah I mean that
was my game of the show last year too
all right whatever you want to leave
this behind try the phone he's got a
spot for you thanks buddy I kill zone I
was a big kill zone multiplayer guy yeah
warzone mode I always baffled me why
more developers did not steal that from
you guys because that just like change
that whole situation for me but seeing
you know seeing the way you guys bring
worlds to life just the artist Rhea it
is down to me last year and it was
exciting to see it in a different way
and sort of that more organic slice of
the game way this year I I think verizon
because we talk about a lot how
different it is for a studio but there
are a ton of similarities to right we we
do really take pride in creating these
these universes and we do have machines
in there you looked at bolts there
there's a lot of guys on the team that
are really great at building these
fantastic Max and and now the machines
and obviously we're trying to have a
beautiful world that leans on gorillas
pedigree and making great technology
great arts what we're really kind of
building on what we learned with with
the kills on franchise it's it's not
really that far either barger in that
sense yeah I mean you gotta you know you
got to carry through your knowledge and
genealogy yeah learn from what you guys
super excel that with kill zone and take
on something entirely new I was it
speaking of entirely new seeing the
player tame the beast during the photos
if they're like that like me especially
the animation touch did it like change
sort of formation like ivory made itself
a little bit and so I think that that
theme sort of the how these robots make
themselves and present themselves it was
something you played a lot with it more
a lot more this time around
so you see in the game that we chose for
a smaller compared to these massive
giant strong machines we have a very
agile and smart character but she's
algun she's out powered by these guys we
gave her a couple of tools from the from
the old ones the old world tools and one
is that focus that she's got behind her
ear and that gives us it gives her a
tactical advantage he can scan she can
find out the weak spots a strong spots
to avoid and she can do that but she
also has that spear and she can override
them and she can either get the machines
to fight alongside of her but some of
the machines she can actually use his
mounts that said it's just fun in an
open world it's just hop on the mound
and cruise around that just explore the
beautiful nature of it absolutely did
you get anybody sort of mo capping
wrestling a yak to get that really
dialed in not yet that's a good idea we
get it yet although it's your calling
I'll send him over to grill and a good
old it rip it like yakking good what's
what's it like to create a world with
kill zone which we played all of them
whatever it's a very advanced world it's
a technological world what was it like
kind of you know with like creating the
distance between this natural overgrown
I guess just hoping I post-apocalyptic
kind of setting with these with these
machines was it a challenge to kind of
make those work together because what's
so surprising about horizon is that it
makes sense when you look at it but it
shouldn't make sense like these machines
walking through at their dinosaurs
people living very primitive lives but
somehow it works together so what was
that a challenge like the matically to
make that happen you know frankly last
year when we came out with the the first
unveiled I feared a little bit that we
were going to be laughed at like these
gorgeous beautiful and nature and then
we throwing these machines and it is the
one thing actually and it surprises me
to an extent that nobody has a problem
with connecting to it nobody things I
haven't really heard that from any of
the other fans or the people that are in
two games that comment on Twitter
whatever that that's that's a stretch
from their imagination they like that
juxtaposition but beautiful lush nature
against and then in that those machines
that are now the dominant life species
they really like that idea which is
great people give us creative freedom
and they like it you're talking about
freedom
and you're also trying to tell me that
it's not that different killzone and
horizon oh there are a couple of
different just making you my world RPG I
mean layout did you like we want to make
this game we pitched this game the game
gets approved at what point are you like
I'll [ __ ] whoa God what are we gonna do
but before the first pitch new
playstation probably yeah yeah no it was
a it was so what we actually did is we
amongst the team would be completed
Killzone 3 that was in 2011 we did a big
round we asked everybody in the studio
you could just pitch ideas yeah and one
of them was this particular concept that
came out and we're like that's kind of
crazy let's look at the other one so
like you know what let's go it was quite
appealing let's go back to it and we
just could not not do it we had to do it
there was so much in it and people just
fell in love for the concept and they
still are in love with the concept at
the studio and I think that's actually
very empowering when you have a team
that loves making what you're what the
current project is it's really really
strong I mean do you think one of the
reasons they love it so much is the fact
that they're getting to stretch their
wings you know I mean every other cliche
right there Killzone is kill zone and
kills nuns awesome and like obviously
you guys did so much different when you
brought to the PlayStation 4 yeah but
now to be in a new genre even doing
different things on that level that like
freeing I guess it's very energizing to
do something that different and and also
we were talking earlier about the
tonality the look of it the grit versus
the majestic beauty the Russian agent
nature that big delta i think is very
empowering to the team they like it a
lot and it's and it's a charted
territory for us we kind of don't know
where it was going initially and people
love exploring they love the freedom of
a very different looking character than
with the the enemies are very different
in it there's so much newness people
generally like news and it's the same in
our studio yeah oh I feel like you know
you had mentioned that after Killzone 3
2011 you guys kind of move on to this
idea yeah you guys also making shadow
fall at the same time all right what how
did you have to kind of craft the team
specifically until I kind of move over
to this kind of game seems like
obviously these games were develops not
currently an you have people
better didn't know how to make a first
person shooter did you have to hire
writers did you have to hire like a
different different staff the kind of a
different group of people to kind of I
guess combined with your staff to make
this day possible yeah we we actually
branched off the the core team of
Killzone 3 and killzone shadow fall was
a new core team that created that title
so it's the it's the old Killzone 2 and
three crew that had creative leadership
and production leadership on it and then
we hired new genres or any new
disciplines that we didn't have on the
team a writer group we have five riders
on staff at the moment with experience
in this this kind of game but also quest
folks from established obviously
developers and that I think we've been
recruiting we started doing that about
four years ago and since about two two
and a half years ago we have a complete
team so we have all those sort of the
missing links we've had that they're now
part of the core team as well do you
feel like and this is something I've
been saying about this game since we saw
it last year and I reiterated it again
if this is executed properly this
strikes me as Sony's next big exclusive
franchise and is that something that you
guys are hoping like it's the war so
deep in the game that you guys hope that
like well let's cut this out of the game
in hopes that we make you know a second
and a third one in the end if I were ten
years that's a big question we we
clearly we're working on something that
has the Lord really asks for deeper like
exploration and we love with a lot
there's there's certainly room to do
more but it's gonna be hard enough to
get the game out and we're now very
committed through the long raid of
februari 28 2017 and that's a promise
but yeah there there's certainly plenty
of depth in this in this in this world
in this universe to explore it further
perfect well speaking of challenges you
know looking at the gameplay demo one of
the most challenging things that seems
to me from a development perspective and
then you know just sort of getting the
player balance right is a loi skillset
as a player it seems you know you
compared to this stuff you could do in
Killzone as you chose different classes
there was a lot on the table but this is
one character but she can do so much
depending on
different tools and they combined in
different ways in different environments
against different creatures so that core
skill set seems to be one of the real
big pillars it must have been there you
know in terms of your design initiative
well it's a it's a role-playing game so
part of a role-playing game is that you
progress your character and what we
showed I forget which exact level she is
in the in the capture that we showed the
press conference think she's a level 12
that means that she she has unlocked
certain skills that you can choose and
one example is the concentration mode
where she's able to slow down the game
so she's got a lot more precision in her
attacks the other one that I see in
there is a silent strike so she takes
out one of those watches by just gliding
underneath it and stabbing it and it's a
one strike kill so these are skills that
you don't necessarily begin with but up
to you're up to your flavor whatever you
like first though these are the ones
that you can pick and build build out
your character well so speaking of these
skills that's one of the ways that an
open-world game will sort of gate areas
you know you can't go over this mountain
pass because you don't have you know the
ability to get two aren't us the
creature that'll take you over it
there's other ways to do that you know
you can have narrative sort of well
we're we're only going to this town once
the story takes us there how are you
guys sort of dealing with that with that
gating of open-world stuff to what
extent are you unlocking new worlds like
that's a player progresses so it is very
much in a seamless overworld but we are
maybe a little bit early to give you the
exact game structure all better but
we're making sure that you are that
you're getting very competent with your
initial set of of abilities and what you
learned first before you venture in but
from the get-go it's the world is quite
open we want it that way yeah I I want
it that way yeah of course when you're
talking about unlocking these new
abilities sliding under precision is it
one that by the end of the game will
call them nice character look similar
like we will unlocked all the same stuff
or is it that there's so much to do as
you begin unlocking it
gonna be focused on our tree I'm gonna
be focused on melee there'll be a
different feel I think the game allows
for a lot of different play styles I
mean it might be that you you explore
your more a stealth caliper no he's more
stealth kind of person here you're more
gung-ho right all right accurate thank
you it I don't know good but it's it
really is is it is all to play a choice
there well not everybody will play this
game a similar way and not everybody
will do everything it's art you
gravitate towards towards your interests
are you comfortable talking about like
open-world RPGs I think there's a big
gamut of this is our open world game
generally this could take dying like to
take 20 hours Skyrim could take a
hundred hours how big is this game like
you guys have internally or in your in
your own mind how long this game will
take someone to beat or you guys not
comfortable talking about all that kind
of stuff yet it's a so the the main
quest line is is very rich its extensive
I don't have any hours to share with you
but there's there's a lot of stuff in
sight west of happening as well there's
a lot of general just open world stuff
and systems coming in that we'll talk
about in a later date but there's a ton
to do you'll be you'll be able to spend
a lot of time in this game because I
guess what I'm saying is I'm so excited
about it that I already don't want to 10
yeah I know right you when you finally
get there you want to play you doing it
kalo we've come to the end already okay
is there anything else you want to do or
yeah absolutely help me open this can
you help me open this this contraption
oh yeah you got it
haha ladies and gentlemen unprecedented
second year in a row you're giving away
you're giving one of your game one of my
game of the show awards the horizon
again Oh congratulate this is my boy had
a beard you probably should have done
different art I've had a beard for two
years number one big guy so he was it's
lazy good for not so hermit I present
you the column Moriarty's seal of
approval once again much don't let me do
it again next year exactly whoa end of
the game now when's the game come if
every 28 2017 all right ladies right
that's Herman that's horizon of course
we want you to go play it when it comes
out we want you stay right here gamespot
com has all sorts of cool III videos
instead of you to rock on such kind of
funny games so go there check it all out
until next time it's been our pleasure
to serve you yeah